des rideaux 9 pour le château de
breteuil trois paires au total pour le
vaisselier la salle à manger
la couleur bleue a été choisi une
nécessité pour être raccord avec les
autres éléments de la pièce c'est une
très jolie soie sauvage que laurence
baby a pu doubler d'une d'un occultant
ce qu' il faut aussi protéger les tissus
et les tapisseries
depuis quatre ans maintenant laurence
baby travail pour le château de breteuil
à son actif trois paires de rideau
refait pour le salon de musique une
paire de rideaux pour le vestibule et
des rideaux occultants pour l'orangerie
un espace dédié aux réceptions on a eu
quand même 80 mètres de tissus ou des
échafaudages pour poser les rideaux
assure qu'on était à 6 mètres sous
plafond et un peu près 20 kg par ha
parle de outre installé à voisins le
bretonneux l' artisan tapissier est
spécialisé dans la création ou la
rénovation de fauteuils ou de rideau
elle a reçu récemment le titre de maître
artisan la plus haute distinction dans
l'artisanat la cia
c'est le petit espace qui existent qu
est vraiment très réduits sur sept ce
petit fauteuil sur l'endroit où l'on
peut mettre tout les accroche c'est
l'ancien coussin de cette bergère qu'on
est en train de restaurer et je vais
faire ce pas ce poids là on a coupé dans
le bief le tissu est
et donc on met une ganse de 3 mm je
passais sous la machine artisan
tapissier un véritable savoir faire
technique entre artisanat et métiers
d'art une activité essentielle dans la
conservation du patrimoine historique
[Musique]